ratio division as the name implies is
about dividing something in a particular
ratio and when we're talking about
something in linear functions it's an
interval okay so here's an interval a B
now something that I'm students often
forget is that you actually already know
ratio division formula it's just it's
for a very particular ratio that's very
very common namely one to one right
if you define something the ratio one to
one you're splitting something in half
so that one piece is exactly the same as
the other right
that ratio division formula one to one
more commonly known as the midpoint
formula right which looks like this
okay so when you are thinking about
ratio division you want to think about
it as okay it's kind of like midpoint
but I want to be a little more finely
controlled I want to pick it's a
particular value not just one to one but
you're going to get something much the
same like think about what's happening
here okay for the x-coordinate you're
taking birth of the x-coordinates that
you start with combining them in some
way and then you're dividing through
right because if you just add them
you're going to be somewhere far away
okay but if you divide you get an
average now if I wanted to buy some
other kind of ratio I'm still going to
combine the X values in somewhere to
bind through them in somewhere and the Y
values are exactly the same okay sort of
look at exactly how we do it let's pick
a point let's call it let's call it P
right now pivot point and I want to know
what the coordinates of this thing are
right this is what I'm trying to find
out so therefore I'm going to call the
coordinates at this point x comma y
they're the unknowns not to be confused
with the x1y1 and x2y2 that are some
numbers you'll be given okay so if we're
dividing this in a ratio we need to know
what the ratio is right now by
convention we use the letters K and L
please note um unlike in many other
places here in quantity amma tree order
as you can imagine is drastically
employment order makes all the
difference if for instance this was 1 to
2 1 to 2 it doesn't take much to see
that if i did it in the ratio two to one
I'd be somewhere else right because I'd
be going the further distance and then
the shorter distance so one to two and
two to one and not the same K - L that's
an alphabetical order and the points
that are given to you a and B will also
be given to you in the order that they
want you to divide in okay so for
example he might be a question davai
interval a B
in the ratio k2l right now in this case
it means you're starting with a going to
be and you're going to do the K portion
first and then the L portion just like
I've shown on my diagram okay so how
we're going to do this
and we're going to take advantage of
similar triangles and so we can draw
some triangles on here
if I draw down a vertical line
horizontally as if I were working out
the gradient and do the same thing yeah
I now have a pair of right-angled
triangles okay because these lines are
perpendicular we've got verticals and
horizontals I also have some parallel
lines and I have a transversal namely a
be sorry corresponding angles equal and
so on so these two triangles are similar
that makes sense we don't need to prove
that we're just using that fact being
that triangle now we need some more
names here I've got a P and B but to be
able to talk about the triangles of a
call this C and D over here triangles
ACP
and try to pay d.b are similar if we
wanted to prove it the reason would be
at the equator
now I'm going to use this so take
advantage of well I want to work out the
exit and then I want to work out the Y's
okay so what relationships do I see
between the XS and the Y's in this
diagram right I can see that for
instance this length here PD right if I
just wanted to work out what this
horizontal length was it's just on the X
values right so how would I calculate it
yeah Benson yeah okay good so x2 is how
far I am away from the axis right and X
is how far this is away from the axis so
this will be the difference X 2 minus X
that's PD you see exactly the same logic
I can get AC right which is slide from X
and I'm taking away X 1 okay so I have
those two distances so now I can come
back
compare different sides to each other
right and they're all ratios so I can
say corresponding sides and similar
triangles in the same ratio right so the
corresponding sides might be say AC and
PD their corresponding sides okay okay
so I can say AC on PD right and the
other pair of corresponding sides the
ones that I do something about other
ones that I've given ratios for right so
they're going to be a P and P B okay and
the reason why course one sided to be
instantly triangles
okay now conceptually that's all there
is to it right just recognizing that
similar triangles relationship of
picking out the right sides from here
let's just do our substitution already
noticed in green what AC and PD are AC
is going to be this MPD is going to be
that by definition these two these
hypotenuse
they're the side pillar and ratio so
I've got K first and then L and all I
want to do here is I'm trying to find
this thing right if I know it's
something different
I want the x coordinate so I just need
to make X the subject you see that okay
so let's just rearranges go to motions
it's not hard
you kind of that just divided sorry I
just cross multiply it and expand it out
here I'm going to make extra subjects
which you'll give me K cell and then
I'll divide through
okay now there are a couple of things in
the notice number one I don't need to go
through this whole process again for the
way those it will play out exactly the
same but with wise instead of X's so I
can just use this and say similarly my
y-coordinate will be L by 1 plus ky2 on
k plus L that'll still be the same okay
secondly please note and this is what is
is drastically confusing for bill okay
alphabetically which one comes first
which ratio which part of HR come first
alphabetically K comes first and then L
but in the formula right in the formula
they're mismatched right L comes first
and then K that's a bit weird I mean if
you write it numerically they switch
over the reason they switch over is
because of what happens in here in the
actual lengths of the sides involved
okay so it's not just random it's like
why can't we just do it the other way
well if you do it the other way you'll
get the opposite ratio and the easiest
way to work out what's going on is just
when you get an actual value for this
right when you take this and you pop it
into this formula do for yourself
uh-huh are you sick of me saying this
yet do it for yourself a rough sketch
and you will be able to tell in like
three seconds whether the point you've
got is like all roughly this way I've
got it right or it's gone that way my
ratio is backwards
I should have flipped these around okay
so there's the formula and you can see
how it makes the midpoint formula right
if your ratio is one to one
this becomes X plus X 2 and this is 1
plus 1 which is 2 and the same thing for
y all right